[Music]
aditi social study your quick catch up
on what celebs are posting online I'm
gonna be cooking with a lot of you Val
Chmerkovskiy has been dating amber rose
for less than five months and has
sparked split rumors by posting a
cryptic message to social media on
Friday that may reveal a change in his
current relationship status the dancing
Pro tweeted if you're ready it's too
late pregnant singer ciara took to
Twitter to share that epic video of her
lip-syncing and dancing baby bump and
all to Whitney Houston's famous song on
the fifth anniversary of the pop icon's
death meanwhile Nick Gordon paid his
respects by posting a pic alongside
Whitney and her daughter bobbi kristina
riding in part i miss you I know you and
Chris are enjoying each other up there
Rih scream queen star Billie lourd
wished boyfriend taylor lautner a happy
birthday by posting this pic of the pair
rockin matching onesies and Ellen
DeGeneres hilariously wished friend
Jennifer Aniston a happy birthday on the
gram posting this montage of her several
visits to the ellen show Teen Mom 2 star
Jenelle Evans announced she and
boyfriend David Eason have quote decided
on forever posting a pic of her
beautiful new ring the couple welcomed
their first child together a baby girl
in January
you
you